[Music]
hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sakya today we have the
pleasure of sitting down also doorman
hello hello hi there
thank you for coming on the show is it
the typical Java handshake as far away
as possible or I sometimes do the two
hands or sometimes we do the Kinect
have you seen the Kinect guys yet they
do this they put their hand up like this
and they look at the other person's eyes
and they go
like okay it's supposed to be that
moment of human connectivity that moment
of understanding that we should go for
peace and this is a lot of what Allison
does she's all about existential hope
this is various what a year ago your and
yeah no well actually it's only hobby
old or something yeah that's crazy it
feels like you've been working on it for
much longer
yeah yeah I think yeah it's more like
the pooling offer that that was half a
year ago but I've definitely you know
when you're like when you think about
the threats for a while and then it just
takes a while to put it together
yeah and essential hope it has this
we're gonna show you show you guys in a
little bit this incredible database of
of what would you what would you say
videos articles its readings podcasts
videos organizations people and and
generally just the best work sometimes
it's just ideas that I linked to someone
who gave them to me in a conversation
and they're all focus on kind of like
how to create the best futures for
Humanity and with best I don't mean in
the sense of like a full utopia but just
how to kind of like shift that mindset
again from this kind of like focus on
this existential angst aspect on one of
existential hope but I'm sure once we go
through it I can explain a little bit
more that if you yes yes the optimizing
the future of humanity and having more
people talking about what what it looked
like and what it should be like so
you're currently at foresight Institute
but rewinding rewinding let's go back to
your journey alright so were you born
and Joanie in in Hamburg
yeah Hamburg and it seems like a couple
left hands ago oh yeah yeah and so how
long did you stay there before moving
from there
and I was there I did my Abitur there
and then I moved to the UK and did
philosophy Portus economics there as an
undergrad and then I did
philosophy and public policy for my
masters at the LSE and then I traveled
around quite a bit done that I'll end it
here and so on your journey how did you
figure out that philosophy was kind of
your thing public policy yeah I think em
philosophy and that it kind of happened
really without any without any input of
mine so since I can remember I've had
this really strong it's got a dislike
for death and that was the thing that
that really always kept me up every
single night since I can remember and
and I came into philosophy about like
trying to figure out how to trying to
reconcile this dislike for death with my
situation because many recognize of my
peers didn't have that fear um and then
I read I started reading a lot of
extensions philosophy and and absurd I
become here was my favor for a while and
eg of course nihilism but um but I kind
of like got got hooked on that and yeah
that was kind of like a guide for a
while and and the interesting thing is I
think that most of this most of those
readings kind of seem to still assume
that death was a given and that we
should just reconcile our lives with it
you know because the struggle against
the absurd and you know myth of sisyphus
like you know like their person rolling
up the up the stone up the hill as as a
happy being but it still took death as a
given and then it only wasn't until
later at university where i discovered
more futurists and probably to
philosophy and like transhumanists to
some extent as well where i kind of like
switched from this position of you know
existentialism to one of like well let's
assume that death might not be a given
right let's take this as a problem that
is solvable rather than something that
is a given and yeah and so that was one
stream of philosophy but the philosophy
that I kind of got most interested in
intellectually because this was more
personal pet peeve of mine though the
the idea of death but then once you get
into philosophy you see that you know
there's really just no end to this ocean
and that every that philosophy is kind
of almost like the ocean which every
everything else kind of like swims in
the sense that you know everything is
embedded in it and I think especially
for all other topics I got really
intellectually interested in AI
philosophy especially AI safety which is
what I did my dissertation then about
but there's really just bits and pieces
but they're all part of this part of
this ocean of philosophy it's just a way
of thinking I think yep I like that that
metaphor it's a massive ocean and every
single aspect of life has something to
do with philosophy and it's really
important to tap into that and converse
with the other intelligent monkeys here
on the planet to try and figure out
arena enabled bio warfare to happen are
we gonna enable nuclear happen are we
going to try and teach every child about
morality so that we don't kill each
other so what are the ways that will
progress forward is something that
you've been passionate about I care
about that so much too and we on the
show talked about it a lot yeah and I
think like what's really interesting in
that regard is I think like philosophy
as a kind of like a tool set right and
you can apply those tools to really any
field and I think most of the time you
know those barriers between different
disciplines are really just artificially
construed and it really helps and lets
you really have to see that because it's
just clear thinking right clear thinking
can be applied to any different problem
and it this is how you reach good
conclusions it's not like you know there
are different sub methods in different
fields but I think it's just about
trying to figure out how to reach how to
get down to the bottom of the truth and
every field really by using good tools
by using logic and reason and free
speech and argument and I think that is
what philosophy teaches you really well
yeah and well first I think all of those
different subfields that I was
interested in like another one and that
was they're kind of like part of my
involvement and also like more of the
political sphere and with flushing
public policy and then also working in
and politics for a little bit was and
this aspect of creating new alternatives
to the current system and creating
better governance mechanisms and and you
know that because I think that getting
that right makes it much more likely
that we get everything else right but to
me those there's interest in longevity
this interests in AI and in an kind of
alternative governance and kind of like
projects like seasteading or or rather
of those projects close but they always
kind of seemed to me like unrelated
until I moved to the babe um and then
suddenly I had was like like wait a
moment people actually care about all of
those things and it was really it was
really to me I mean the Bears often
called a bubble right because people you
know like live in those like living the
the silos of this kind of like you know
like kind of like more futurists well
being focused and kind of excited that
is enabled by technology but for me it
was really not an anchor chamber and
it's isn't because I was not ever in
that kind of community before so coming
here and suddenly realizing because I
did effective altruism as well at
university but more in the sense that
back then it was still a little bit more
current focused like trying to do good
right now and now that it has become a
little bit more futurists with AI safety
it kind of seems like in the betas it
pulls all those strings together right
you have this alternative society
building movement of like see sitting on
of the blockchain ecosystem you have
people working on AI and AI safety you
have people that are really concerned
about getting about really making sure
that that we create well-being for
future generations as well yeah and
suddenly all of the only long 72 right
it's it's a really big big project here
and suddenly all of those threats were
pulled together and I was um I was
flabbergasted that people care about
really the same things and and many of
them
Peter Thiel talks a lot about the whole
network affect the fact that everybody's
migrating here and when does it all want
us to stop being worth the egregious
amount of money to live here and for me
I don't think you'll ever stop
I love the network effect I love the
diversity of intellect
I love the interdisciplinary approaches
to studying and to working together to
build the future and leave it better for
other generations I don't think that
echo chamber is going to hear the bubble
is going to stop and the echo chamber of
all the future is yeah hawk is going to
stop and I think that that's really
important because it almost gives us a
long now review the whole 1,000 year
view and I think that's really important
as I think a lot of people here are
building that future going back another
thing that you said was your you
philosophy gives you this tool set logic
reasoning ability to have a outstanding
conversation with somebody else one that
isn't filled with bias and rage and all
these other things that we see so much
polarization in the world so I love that
tool set it's like you got it you got to
equip yourself with the belt yeah and
then you got to be able to take out the
different tools yeah and use them as you
go and you're talking about systems of
governance so and that's kind of what
you're doing a little this is something
that I really want to wander down with
you and let's maybe wander down that a
bit and then we'll open up Essential
hope and we'll look through it is there
a golden key to how we shall move into
the future yeah I think the this spawns
government right but it's I think it's a
subset really of the question and okay
so a thing that I've become am really
interested in recently is different
ideas of utopia so utopia is often kind
of like you know considers this one
perfect this one perfect goal that we
can march towards and the you know the
in philosophy there are different
dialectics like the Hegelian dialectic
dialectic of reaching it or should we
ever even reach it because utopia might
be boring or unattainable
because you need some suffering and for
that actually I wrote a really cool
piece kind of doubting that can you walk
us down that piece quick on the way yeah
so it's it's also on the index but he
basically goes through a couple of a
couple of reasons why utopia is not
boring and and why you don't need
suffering yeah yes it's more like a
diversity and he lists a bunch of like I
think really interesting interesting
things that make a utopia worthwhile but
I think more than creating a perfect
utopia for me it is really about um kind
of figuring out what is the next step
that we can take to leave all the good
options open and not foreclose them and
and that while still having this
motivation to reach that next step so a
couple of other theories that have been
there that reasonably just popped up
one is I developed this like version of
Pro Toto Pia and the reason to develop
this was a Burning Man cam so we're
doing a Burning Man camp this year focus
on Pro Toto Pia and the idea was really
here that you know in the community
where I live so I live in a group house
we kind of definitely have really high
ideals we're holding ourselves to really
high standards but we're just you know
trying to figure it out really and so it
has this ha like humility to it and
we're prototyping our way to utopia and
just when like when I when I recently
read a quartz article I discovered that
Kevin Kelly has a similar concept of a
proto Pia so probably like along the
same lines it's a little different but
but there was another one that popped up
and then a third one that I heard um two
days ago I think was Pareto topia um and
I I really liked that too right because
I really think that my own personal
utopia would be a utopia in which every
human can construe their own utopia so
it's not one ideal but it leaves enough
space for every human to engage in
whatever they what is it
whatever's in their interest while
making it not not impossible for others
to do so and as long as it doesn't harm
other exactly yeah yeah
yep the Pareto principle of like you
know engaging in voluntary interaction
and then leading to Pareto preferred
outcomes which you know makes you best
off by making the one most often there's
no better state they could do that I
think that notion has a really powerful
one is that like the Golden Rule treat
others where you want to be treated no
it's it's not really that it's more like
in in interactions of individuals Pareto
preferred outcomes are for example game
theory
outcomes where you cannot move to a
better state for yourself without making
someone who are self so no one would
prefer to move given that give me a
state and I think that is an interesting
one because it doesn't rely on as you
know having it figured out yet you know
I didn't really buy two apples we have
two apples that are sitting there either
I take one and you take one there I take
two or you take I think it's a notion
that and and I'm not saying that you
know that we're currently doing it
perfectly but I do think that not that
we are really just on the verge of
tapping into that we might know and
given the kind of like rate of progress
and of more progress so far we can't
assume that we figured it out right now
you know like looking back in a hundred
years we would probably have figured out
that shooting animals the way that we do
kind of you know it's based on species
biases and not having any regard for
future generations is based on kind of
like you know a short time bias that we
have towards us so wanting to lock our
values in right now by saying oh this is
the Utopia that we should create that
that's not I think what we should be
doing and what we should rather be doing
is to create systems in which which can
be dynamic towards progress and it you
know which rely on people figuring it
out together as a collective so but
figuring it out together as a collective
also requires us to make some base set
principles to thrive on like not killing
each other
yeah that's a good one yes so so even if
everybody thrives in their own utopia
wants to live in their own space well if
they want to manufacture weapons and
sell weapons to people and then I mean
yeah I mean that's that's the notion of
like you know and that you have to have
a system which enables voluntary
interaction amongst individuals and
there's voluntary action voluntary
interactions in and there's definitely
some ways you know that that one might
be able to make that happen I think um
one way of often enshrining that and
that that's you know really talking
about like specifics here and I do I do
believe in the notion of a universal
basic income and to the extent that we
should at least we should really try
this out and in a paper that Christine
Peterson Mark Miller and I wrote which I
coming to from the index I mean it's
already on the index but I can link also
to it and the video we come up with this
we don't come up with a with the concept
but we revisit a concept that eric
drexler has put forth and engines of
creation which was the book that kind of
started for set of em and it's called
inheritance day so the way that you
might fund ubi um it's basically and
this might sound a little out there but
it's basically not by trying to
redistribute resources and to fund ubi
because you know the the elite and power
will will probably will probably go
against this but rather than be
distributing resources that are already
distributed to you know different
individuals or needs why not just say
well is there any resource out there
that isn't distributed yet and there is
in that space and so it's like land or
space like outer space and so resources
in space and will one day be extremely
valuable and before any one corporation
goes there and claims it to themselves
and which will just exacerbate the the
problem of the problem that we can you
already have
why not try to find a way to make it
accessible to all so that all can
benefit from it this requires capitalism
to create and the engine of the
spaceship that goes and harvests the
asteroid or whatever you're trying to
mine for resources yeah it's not that
person would want to own it yeah I mean
it's more about if you could and there's
different cake-cutting algorithms to do
that and my team published a paper a
little while ago on a new cake-cutting
algorithm if you could divide the
resources in space such that every human
being at who's alive at a particular
point in time and maybe over 18 or 21 or
whatever on that day which is called
inheritance day gets a chunk of the
resources out there in space and since
space is so vast it would be really a
lot for every individual if they got a
resource out in space and even if they
can't do anything with it they could
trade with it right so the whoever wants
to do something with it can you know
give something back in return right so
it well it wouldn't be that it we each
build out on spaceship and go up there
but it's really just as a means of of
trade of making those more voluntary
interactions possible again right and I
mean the main criticism that we get is
like well but in one generation people
will have just traded away everything
and it will just look like before you
know but now with corporations owning
whatever they have kind of acquired
because they trick people into um into
selling their share of the universe
right or they explore people into
selling their share and I think you know
and that certainly possibility but you
could install something like a font you
smile contract based fun that only gives
you a certain amount of space space uses
it as you grow up and this is an idea
that sounds out there that's interesting
cake-cutting space yeah that's funny
yeah I mean giving it's every person on
their 18th birthday yeah I mean I I just
think that generally space will have an
immense value and we still are in this
crazy position where no one has claimed
it in a way
that we can't do anything about it and
and so I think we should really worry
about our oceans yeah but I mean space
the resources that are in space are just
so and so valuable that and and there
I've there are enough efforts you know
that have popped up in the past years of
people working really hard to get out
there and and to harness those reasons
one could say the same thing about our
oceans not as abundant as space but
there are a lot that we could take away
from our oceans like a mean fish you
know like yeah like it was like what's
valuable what's defensible oh yeah
probably quite didn't quite the myriad
of resources on the ocean floor well I
mean III would just assume that if it's
feasible to extract them they would they
would have been expected and it's not
like people are not trying right and so
I just think that well how much more
feasible is it to go and mine an
asteroid and bring it back to earth well
I mean talking are we talking about
right now or are we talking about
setting the right kind of like legal
framework that book guide us into a
future which is beneficial for everyone
and then space is definitely on the
table read so hopefully it's on the
table it is I like the idea of
leveraging space resources for ubi
it's fascinating I've also stumbled up
into this that's been fueling me for a
while is that universal basic income can
be funded by the data that we leave
behind so you are actually in control of
your data and you have access control to
deliver it to the different locations
they'll pay you for your data yeah I
mean then I think that's a really nice
idea but the problem I think is and I
you know without wanting to go too much
into the Facebook problematic or I think
to me actually Facebook programmatics
much bigger than Facebook it's just an
internet problematic right now we've
constructed a suboptimal internet I
think and first that was really involved
with like high
hepatech Xanadu in the early days which
was I think a much more interesting
layer of the internet with backlinks and
but and regardless of that I think what
I think that it would be great if people
could Bank on their data but we are
already banking on our data in the sense
that we get free access to information
and that we get a social network called
Facebook so I think unless people are
not willing to pay for access to those
to those social networks or to access to
information think about the money
Facebook makes so much money I don't
even know how much couple dozens of
billions of dollars per year on
advertising that money redistributed so
that the shareholders don't take the
sloth of that but that people take a lot
of that home then we might be able to
get to a point where your data is
actually worth something to you and you
get access to their product and their
shareholders get to take home money at
the same time another biggest problem of
des is it's just a corporate greed is
that I want a third vote before I want
to pay a million people for their data
well I mean I think the whole it's just
the incentives that are so aligned in
the internet right so the internet works
on advertisement right this this is the
thing that is enshrined in the internet
it's not just Facebook and electro he
said suboptimal it or no yeah it's it's
I mean it was a better there was a bit
of version out there but you know for
idiot syncretic reasons at the time and
I think it wasn't implemented and
because it's just more complex right or
more complicated to do but I do think
that there is a potential there's a vast
potential to do better and I accept I
totally agree with that and I just moved
to the embassy and and someone Cisco and
Tristan Harris lives there too started
well first time well spent and the
Center for humane technology now and I
think their work is incredibly
interesting and he's very committed and
I love their work yeah
so I people are waking up to it I think
and
and it's an important problem to take up
for sure I'm happy that we got into this
crazy cosmic ubi discussion because I
think there's not enough conversations
about how to actually execute the
processes the especially in the short
term and I know we could unpack that
further because I think that we're
missing a couple pieces from that maybe
missing couple pieces from the data ubi
one solty Nissan wants to do the
National Land he wants to lease out
national land and pay people in
California there's there's a bunch of
different ones and I think that it's
good let's let's pull up existential
hope ok yeah because so maybe that's
interesting for the viewers most of the
things they were discussing here or like
the the reference that talks or whatever
I reference the readings are on the
index or if you're interested in any of
the things that I mentioned there you
can find them there and so here we are
we're at existential help calm and I
love this I love this back of this
graphic yeah it's very well at Macau
it's a really great great image I'm
gonna pull it up on your on your
Facebook but it has a little bit of like
a Soviet touch of utopia but you know
it's a III and I could
because I think it combines this you
know there's not it's not just a techno
topia but it it has this yeah there we
go it's damaged yeah
I was about look I'm number 69 haha
that's so funny number 69 69 there you
go is my favorite number so that's
interesting for me alright
so nice so this is Robert McCall yeah
this is beautiful I really love it we
got some like governance here we got a
little bit of like some Soviet that
looks like some Soviet European action
here some humans bunch of humans diverse
humans still some animals we got some
people looking like they're flying over
here which is great we have this like
massive like spaceship structure or
futuristic and stuff water fountain we
still have a star in the cosmos and
planets and your body looks like some
space stations and some LEP looks like
we're using nuclear fusion to power some
of this stuff yeah and I think I would I
think it brings home like the reasons I
mean to start that index which was like
the personal reason of course was I
wanted to kind of do to the existential
risk kind of like feeling that I had
which in my research of an AI safety
researcher but I also do like computer
like cybersecurity risk research right
now and and I wanted to do to this kind
of like sober attitude because in in the
everyday life and if you look at those
risks you almost seem to make that I am
just doubt whether we even make it
through the century right like not just
AI risk but pajama risk and then make
sure and and then now news being nuclear
weapons being back on the table again
which we thought we'd eradicated in
propaganda think you know it it's it's
kind of like hazing the Turing Turing
test well yeah it's just this Morin like
pessimist
I'm pessimist kind of like attitude that
you get to it but also I think generally
risk research is more like this neutral
kind of like very rational assessment of
risk and that's what you know what is
really important you do and it's
important that it's unbiased right it's
very important but on the other hand it
sometimes makes you forget why you even
care and I think it kind of like how to
say take it and it settles the horse
from the wrong way what's the the
English term for this
that's funny saddles the horse from it
split puts the cart before the horse
that's the English way of saying it the
German way is is a different one and so
it kind of like it kind of like in
focusing so much on the risks we forget
why we're even doing this and I think
why we're doing this is a really
motivational component because if we
make it through this bottleneck we're in
this real bottleneck right now where we
can either really meat into order really
good feature or we could really get
extinct and we're at this bottleneck
right now which I think and in an
unproven unraveling and in ways before
so I think it's really important to
remind ourselves why we absolutely have
to get this right to it rather than just
focusing on oh well and you know
survival would be a success that
focusing in like if we get this right
it's not only survival that we get but
if we get this right the futures not
going to look just plain but it could be
really so much better so so the why is
to survive and have a great future yeah
I mean like I think survival is already
if we survive it's very unlikely I think
that we will have a terrible future
because correct given yes but but it's
also likely that if we survive that we
do have a terrible future because there
is a class based speciation that will
occur it's actually quite likely to
occur the amount of wealth that's
accumulated that the economy grows by so
much every decade now because of
information technology and then it's
captured mostly by the 1% the growth of
the economy
so why would they ever want to engage or
interact with the
poor or middle-class at all bill gates
can't even people he was playing a game
on The Ellen DeGeneres Show where he had
to guess the prices of grocery store
items and he thought that of like he
thought that a 40 pack of tostitos pizza
rolls he thought that was 20 dollars
he thought the Tide Pods you know the
big box of Tide Pods he thought that
that was four dollars so what I'm
getting at is that there's already such
a huge disconnect between the ultra rich
and the poor in middle class that
there's we can't just say that if we
make it through the bottleneck
everything will be great because the
likelihood that we first make it through
the bottleneck that's crucial to survive
and the second stages if we survive or
is everybody going to flourish like we
have in this beautiful example by Robert
or is there gonna be some king up in
this castle up here at the top of the
utopic structure that is a benevolent
dictator or could they be a group of
twenty people that are trying to
progress everybody forward or is it
going to be like none of these peasants
on the hills can have the option of
entering the castle okay so I think
talking about that that we get is again
I think into a rabbit hole but I think
it's important to not forget how much
progress we've made and I think at the
event where you were on Sunday and we
hosted an event logs about it artificial
general intelligence as corporations and
Mark Miller who's got this breakfast and
solid brothers you know like this
backdrop of really how much we have
progressed like in terms of absolute
poverty and and its really implemented
or - yeah yeah and it is a graph I think
that Pinker use is great but you know
and I think it's really really really
important to not forget how far we've
come and and we understand how far we've
got okay okay yeah so I mean I I agree
that there's a lot to work to be done to
ensure that their futures are positive
rather than negative right and that
there's a lot of work that is not
technocratic and take the standard but
that has to be done on different areas
and that's why okay so maybe if we
into the index a little bit then it
might become more clear that what this
vision actually entails yeah so I would
still like to add you know you were
saying we should we won't go down that
rabbit hole when it's full but that is
something really important to discuss
it's at some point let's let's go
through this we have time at the end we
will yeah I just think that it becomes
clearer down here so for example mmm
okay so the reason why why I started
this was really just kind of like
collecting readings organizations
podcast papers books people and
organizations and that work to work
beneficial futures so that two features
that give you kind of like a hope again
rather than existential angst and terror
and it's not it really over this vision
part right I just wanted to collect like
really good readings and transhumanism
and kosm ISM and risk and threats and
extension angst and hope and and then
but also readings in big history and big
future because I think the best way to
have foresight is to really also
consider the past right and like this
historic analysis and it's important but
then it became much more than that and I
was thinking well now that we do know
kind of like what are the features that
we could strive for one of the different
focus areas and so I made a say I made a
second section with you know like given
that if we agree on this vision that we
can create these futures what are the
focus areas that we need to work on
until we have science and tech ions AI
in cyberspace but we also have society
in economics right and this is I think
one which is really important which
you've been bringing up over and over
again and which is like the bedrock on
which everything else gets made so it is
the fundamental thing to get right and
and I'll talk about like one thing that
I'm doing for that in a second but the
third one is then given that we know the
focus areas you know here are the tools
and those are really meta tools like
loss and rationality minor meditation
like the toolkit that we discussed yeah
and we know how what given that we know
the vision and the focus areas which are
the tools that we can apply to them and
if you you know click on any of those I
mean I think that
that we used here for at the event at
the event on Sunday was the AI section
and you know if you click on one of
those items that links you to a Google
Doc yeah and on that Google Doc I you
know come I combine like the best
readings on on AI safety on different
terms on ethics and the good thing is
that it's fantastic it's a great place
for people to come and learn yeah yeah
and I and I hope not only learn but also
contribute because I'm not an expert in
all of those and honestly not in either
of those fields because I've just
started this and I think like over 90
percent of this is still all for me it's
just me can make brain dumping well what
good readings yeah I find that I would
really like this to be a collaborative
project so if you find this interesting
and if you are happen to be a researcher
that focuses on any one of those fields
that were on the index then please just
go on there click on the one that you
focus on maybe you work in environment
energy click on it and then you get you
know the director to the Google Doc and
you can make comments on suggestions of
important readings in your field and I
will I want every once in a while sweep
the website and put those comments on
there and and then it becomes a
collective effort to put together this
database of information I've existential
hope but also of collaboration to build
that future together yeah yes I want and
desperately need that's funny what we're
doing is very similar because our
contents are show content goes under
these categories as well so we have a
whole subsection of people on our show
that talk about biotech we have a whole
subsection of people on our show to talk
about blog yeah so we could even put
potentially our video links to our
conversations into Keystone into the
program as well and then as well on our
website under each section of of like Oh
blockchain videos oh by the way here's
existential hopes blockchain doc and
then boom like I was enough elaboration
with that because we're both kind of
building out this this set of
information that we think is very wise
and important to discuss
to build the future inspire people to
talk about and build it so that's that's
one of the reasons why I think that I've
always been gravitating towards your
mind and your impact is because you have
this big vision this big picture
understanding of kind of what's going on
and what's important and that's kind of
what we do on the show as well as with
this multidisciplinary understanding of
what's what's what is society and where
society going yeah I think we're
philosophy maybe comes in handy is like
that you can create a good overview
effect yeah I do always point out that I
have dangers half knowledge in many of
those topics right so it comes you know
it comes with non specialization in any
of those fields right I know enough to
think that yeah you know this is an
important thing but I really depend on
everyone out there to fill those gaps
and who if you specialize in one of
those fields yeah and I think I'm just
quickly to not touch your point on you
know the kind of societal aspect or the
socio-economic aspect of building good
features that you raise and that's under
society and economic I mean there are
some readings but one thing that we've
recently
yeah the but one thing that foresight is
doing now and I can link to that as well
is basically I've started this so we're
doing salons and once a month right now
which open to the public in which kind
of inform our thinking about which
technologies to push to push for and
which risks to research and on recently
this year I've started this kind of
series of salons that are on like
debunking a certain type and the reason
to debunk to debunk something is because
I overall I want that whole series of
salons to be an strengthening
civilization yep
so that's a really big it's a mouthful
so amongst that topic of strengthening
civilizations I take one month each to
focus on a specific sub problem and
civilization so January was on debunking
rationality so we applied like
evolutionary psychology evolutionary
game theory and Link and another
strategies to find out what other biases
that we rationally prone to and how do
they refrain us from from just being an
effective individual and
that we want to pursue that was
rationality then - then sorry on on
February it was we had Junoon on counter
culture because culture is an important
thing of civilization so we were
debunking culture counter culture and
counter culture with them again using
mostly tools from you know evolutionary
biology evolutionary psychology then we
had Robin Hanson on and he was debunking
society mostly like our hidden motives
and incentives and then recently I did
one on morality and that was kind of as
a preparation for a South by Southwest
workshop that I held in the video I
uploaded tomorrow if you interested in
have Mel debunking and maybe we can talk
about that a little later but that there
are like yeah that's like basically how
do we have an unbiased approach to
morality and now with sama boja who
actually should really be on the show
he's so Sam Ibaka I got Abu huh yeah I
can connect you to me and he gave one of
the best talks that I've seen it
effective altruism two years ago and he
gave an answer on the embassy and he's a
historian and with him I'm hoping to do
us along very soon on on the broad
picture of debunking civilization and
let's [ __ ] civilization yeah
everything yeah in like the the previous
ones were about you know debunking
rationality debug morality debunking
culture meaning just under spitter and
it's making a part taking a part of why
why we think about it the way that that
that we do and that often involves an
evolutionary is perspective on or at
least a historical one I'm a different
issue
definitely so how did there's another
matter is they're going to yeah and
which which are the incentive structures
actually that led over time you know and
over many iterations of the games that
we play with each other led to the
situation over in right now and what can
we learn from that to create better
structures but of better projects going
forward that take the incentive
structures into account and also the
it has developed yeah so that's it's a
mouthful and it's a it's a big project
but I'm hoping by splitting it up into
one salon each per month it will become
eventually tangible or more tangible
yeah and then also adding that to the
existential hope database yeah
maybe writing a book about it or making
a documentary if I can tap into the
space-time fabric and figure out how to
work myself some more time yeah then I
will write a book or my documentary she
says this is it's good I'm glad so
what's uh that was you counterculture
so it's been four of these and now
you're on maize is next yeah yep
may its next and I mean there's a lot
happening right now and as so yeah we're
planning on doing another one fairly
soon it would it might it might already
be May but since we had and what is it
now April yes anything but since we had
the AI workshop that kind of like you
know what counts one out this I lost but
as soon as possible really and you know
those things about a bioethics one who's
that career yes it's coming up it is
actually in the planning and we are
talking to I mean we've already
partnered with with any by oh yeah and
so we where there will be a salon on
that one as well
and but yeah but I think to me and I
think this is really important and it
kind of ties in with the approach kind
of to AI safety that you know we have at
foresight we just kind of like a more
broader perspective on AI and I would
love to do talk about that tooth oh yeah
yeah I feel like we have we have so many
ways to to take this conversation I know
I'm just like okay with Tyler ultimen
and we were like you know whenever you
start talking during the conversation
you can have like suddenly like tree off
you know until like one direction and it
would be great to have an index
index and actually follow up the tree
Dom all the way down that rabbit hole
and then come up again and then move the
conversation forward I think would take
a while you know but if we just had a
big sheet of paper and then we wrote the
individual keyword as we went and then
or if an artist could make it as you go
on like a big board themselves some
people do that with live conversations
down the line when we do these more
massive live events maybe we do to them
maybe we get to a point where it's so
the show so well-funded patreon that we
can bring somebody in-house to make
animations as we as we go that can show
the conversation tree and okay so if we
were to go back to a point or maybe even
if we go forward to one of the things
that we need to talk about because I
think let let us go to some of these
things so the centralization why is the
centralization important as we move
forward into the future so I think that
you know I think we've touched about
this multiple times already doing the
conversation but I think creating one
utopia with one perfect kind of like
vision and will has has not worked in
historically and might not work moving
forward so I think the sanitization um
you know has become this buzzword right
now but actually if you if you look at
it if you look at the whole the system
as a whole in which in which we live in
and I think most of how are tied into AI
safety research is like most of the most
of the most of the safety research in AI
safety kind of seems to seem to presume
that artificial intelligence will be
this single agent or like oh not a
single moment like this single agent
that we create that will will be an
artificial kind of like an artificially
not a fishy agent that is kind of
different to us in in so far that it has
a utility function
and that utility function is then the
question is then how do you line that
utility function with our interest as
civilization and this is a problem that
is really hard right because first of
all you have to solve ethics for that
yet we have to know what it is what what
what what are the values that we want
that agent to uphold they may have to
figure out a way of how to communicate
this to an agent in a way that some an
agent that doesn't share our
evolutionary history apart from the fact
that we made it can actually follow suit
super that and then I think there's a
cybersecurity aspect which is very very
important and and which often gets
neglected even if we figure out you know
like what the malls where that we want
to enshrine and if we figured out the
correct way of aligning that AI with
those morals then we'd still need to
solve the architecture and make that
sufficiently safe that we can expect the
agent to reliably execute and whatever
whatever goals we'd like to do we'd like
it to uphold and then of course given
that all of those three take a really
big time to solve it's all those three
years are really different difficult
problems then you have this kind of like
this meta problem effect how do you make
the the agents right now that are
working on that problem cooperate with
each other right there's many different
kind of entities working toward a I it's
not only nation-states its companies -
how do you make sure that those um you
know different agents cooperate in a way
that then there's no race that you know
cuts corners so I think all of those
problems are really hard problems and as
you see with the trade wars right now
right and as you see with China's
proposed AI budget which kind of troughs
the u.s. budget a race is really likely
and we have to we have to really prevent
it at all costs and for setters and I
will host a meeting on that later this
year and I'm hoping to take of it but
all of those four issues are really
important and they're they're each sub
subsection is so hard that it's it's
it's um
it's really important to get it right
and I think what we then did at
foresight was like to UM kind of take a
stay bad take a step back and think
think about kind of like how do we think
about intelligence from kind of these
first principles why is it that we're
worried about intelligence
well because intelligence and is this
thing that gives rise to everything else
and it's this insane multiplying factor
but we're not really worried about the
artificiality so much as you know
wanting to create an and by all means
wanted to create an artificial being so
then let's think about intelligence and
what it means and for us that means
really problem-solving ability and that
can be by an agent but it could also be
by a system and to us really
civilization is the system that is best
at problem-solving that we currently
know of and in the sense that you know
if you have an a system that you know
contains only like algae and fish they
solve a subproblems of at this of the
problems of like creating and using
light right and then if you have another
problem and if you have another system
that contains humans as well they will
solve a broader variety of problems but
then if you have an even larger system
can tell could any use in humans and
Bell Labs that we could solve many more
problems but if you have civilization as
a whole this is really the biggest
containing the biggest system that's all
that is able to solve the most problems
so we think that civilization as a thing
in itself is already super intelligent
and it already serves human interests in
how I described earlier and towards this
conversation in the sense that it
enables per like that it enables
interactions that are peretta preferred
by the individuals and it does that
imperfectly but over time really you
know what Steven pink and as others have
pointed out we're really on an ok path
right but it does feel better and better
we create institutions that are more
enabling of interactions that are more
enabling of individuals reaching their
interests and that is this tropism that
tends to go into the right direction so
rather than you know taking a step back
rather than trying to create this new
artificial entity and then trying to
make it such that the utility function
of that entity serves human interest
even though they're very different why
not try to enshrine in the emergent AI
into the system there is already super
intelligence which is civilization and
that already serves human interests and
this is why also the series of salons
are like how do we strengthen
civilization so that we can make it more
likely that we can incorporate a eyesore
yeah and try a mesh a eyes into the
system yeah rather than investing our
efforts into an AI on the external side
of our super civilization or super
intelligence and try and make it utility
based on what we want it to do maybe we
should bring it right into our super
intelligent problem-solving ability
right away and and kind of bring it in
in that sense so there's a bunch of
other topics that we have listed that we
should talk about but we've already been
talking about them as we've been going
pretty much
what are your thoughts about longevity
right now um I think that longevity
I certainly have certainly come to two
better terms with longevity um in in the
sense that I think it's a it's a much
more soul problem than what I used to
think when I was living in Germany and I
think that there's several different
fallacies around longevity that when you
ask people you know do you want to do
you want to live indefinitely they say
no and they think that with live
indefinitely we mean you know like
living and hopefully indefinitely but um
to me what really woke me up to this is
if you would plot if you would ask
people when is it bad to die in your
life right they would usually think that
it's not so bad to die as a baby because
you haven't made any investments here
towards your future self then it gets
progressively worse as you get older it
gets worse and ways to die as a teenager
you've now you at school you're making
you know investments to what your future
and you invest in your ecosystem around
you people value you value them and then
you know if you make all those
investments eventually you have this
life narrative if you cash out on them
you have a good job and then it gets
less and less bad to die and as you get
older and as you've you know how to your
perfect life narrative and like you know
it's as wholesome one one narrator
narration of life circle circle but what
I don't agree that it gets worse today
but I don't agree that it gets less bad
to die at the end of it I actually think
that the reason why we think that it
gets less fair to die at the end of it
is maybe for three reasons maybe we
don't even think that maybe we think
that elderly people think that but they
don't actually do my grandma told me
that she doesn't she is merely scared of
death and she really loves everyone
around me a lot everyone around her a
lot secondly if they do think that it
gets less bad to die when they're old
then that's I think because they think
because they're frail and old right and
because they are ill they have the
disease of aging which we all have but
they have it as a at a much more
advanced level so they are just
unhealthy and no one wants to live in an
unhealthy way
if they you know we're to give him back
like youthful vigor than the I'm certain
they would they would want to live
longer and then the third one is that
even if they say that they don't I think
that is absurd
protection mechanism given that they
know that they're going to die that we
don't have the cell is easier to help
prevent them die and I think people just
shut down right before that it was God
and religion in the afterlife and now
it's just like oh it's okay
I've had my life narrative and that is
the psychological tool that they use I
think to doubt to to kind of down to
update their preferences downward or
their expectations of life downward and
to just expect this whereas I think what
we should be saying is like that that's
not the default right it doesn't have to
be the endpoint of life and I think once
if we this is weird almost like you know
shake and egg problem you know you first
have to present them with some viable
solution until they were actually you
know really want to go for it but I do
think that there's a lot more well-being
to be attained and and and I of the
believe that or of the hope really then
that I will not have to die yeah I want
to see how long civilization prospers
and how it does we already think it's
it's all about the 27 club any White
House Kurt Cobain Jimi Hendrix Jim
Morrison coming in balls to the wall
live your life don't give a [ __ ] and get
out at before you thirty all right well
then I would have four more for my years
I've known well you know I you are you
living your life with that zest of those
superstars that left their mark and and
and will never die as long as you know
we continue to listen to their music and
study their life and I do but I also I
mean I'm coming here at the closet here
and which is not much of a closet
someone says cool but I mean I'm signed
up to cryonics I'm signed up to forever
labs I'm doing intimate fasting so I am
taking steps toward ensuring that I
won't end if even if
I even if I do die and which I think
might be the wrong terminology then at
least it might just be you know a
vitrified state for a while before that
changes again yeah I hope that we can
get to a point where we don't need to
leave our consciousness for a period of
time and then come back hopefully we can
just stay through the whole thing
that's good that you're signed up for it
and exploring it what do you think about
the crypto frenzy and I think okay I
think so I'm I was with the
research-wise we thought about the
blockchain ëcoz ecosystem in the sense
that is relevant to cyber security
because one thing you know where
civilization really needs a boost right
now also where AI is really really
struggling or will be struggling with I
think is cyber security and I think a
really good like a role model to look at
is the blockchain ecosystem because
while the current kind of infrastructure
that we're living in is kind of based on
insecure foundations they're not been
secure they're insecure all right and
they've been around for a while and it's
getting worse and worse because we built
more and more on top of those structures
that are in securable those
computational structures and also the
algorithm or like ciphertext becomes
more and more sophisticated so cyber
security is already a huge problem I
think on Iran like few days ago there
that it showed this message it showed us
flags on Iran's websites like cyber
security has geopolitical consequences
and and there's a lot of threats in
terms of self-driving cars drones and
maybe even like I read the paper
yesterday on pacemakers being a problem
because you could potentially send
viruses from one to one because the
networks right now are really unsecured
so that viruses can travel so here you
have a real connection between
cybersecurity and biotech but um one way
how you might solve the cyber security
issue and for that is has taken this
really to a heart because it is
neglected not only generally but also an
AI say
and Mark Miller who's a four-set fellow
he's he's really an expert on this and
he has this theory of object
capabilities which is great there's a
lot of technical papers on this if
you're interested but where I think the
kind of the blockchain system is
interesting to me is not so much in
terms of the crypto frenzy right now and
also not so much in terms of many of the
icos that are um that are popping up
left and right now even though I think
they are all pushing many of them have
really good intentions and they're
pushing for the really right thing right
if the road is a frenzy but I'm really
interested in how the ecosystem as a
whole if you look back will it's
beneficial or not and the ecosystem as a
whole is beneficial in the way that bad
projects get killed really early and
visibly you know so you had to attack on
the Dow like that was crazy right and
it's really great for cybersecurity
because um systems that are not secure
will not survive and they will die early
and visibly just like you know the
application that was built on top of a
theorem which was the Dow got killed
early and visibly because there is these
you know million-dollar bug bounties
that hackers have an incentive to
actually attack the system so the system
is hostile enough that there's enough
incentive to attack which breeds the
security aspect so it's almost like a
feature of your startup or your ICO that
the total that you create that it's
secure so I think that's really great
and then you know I think that as a meta
point on the on the crypto frenzy I
think there are really valuable kind of
almost at you know like anthropocentric
or like well anthropological
observations about the system as a whole
and how it interacts with the current
system and if we really were able if
that blockchain system was able to
perform a genetic takeover of the
current system we would be in a much
more secure state in terms of cyber
cyber security and then generally I
think it's great what you know and the
pineapple fund and and other guys are
doing and in terms of kind of growing
into their role
of being really powerful agents in this
world and I think you know right now the
cryptocurrency see nothing gets
portrayed as this hedonistic you know
like you know um hedonistic ecosystem
that is like you know a bunch of people
bitching that I ciose to each other and
hire an ayahuasca or something on on a
boat but I do think that many of them
many of the early investors especially
and many people that are trying to build
value are there for the right reasons
and we're really lucky because those are
people that have a mindset that is like
open source that um agrees with far
future technologies that is already a
taking a lot like that is a kind of fact
more or less a responsible mindset that
was already and meshed in in this
technological ecosystem really early on
that's why they you know that's why they
were early in in cryptocurrencies and so
they are already caring about the right
things I think so and many of them are
waking up already to the responsibility
in to the role that they could play
right some of them I think still suffer
from this nobility buyers of like you
know like almost treating it as a win
you know the the wealth that they
created but many of them are really
growing into their role and I would love
to I would love to see more of that
happening and for that is accepting
cryptocurrency donation so involvement
yeah yeah if anyone feels inclined
please donate you we have a couple of
projects on the line that we could be
doing with more with more donations some
in the cyber security space some
specific problems on AI coordination we
have longevity projects and we're
starting probably a series of longevity
salon soon but it usually requires
education and I would like to do more
and strengthening civilization and I
think it's a project that is good
regardless of whether you think super
intelligence is a civilization
civilizations a super intelligence or
not it's always good
right and there's really a lot we could
do and Robin Hanson said it right I
think by saying well you know people
donate often to charity for for
signaling to their other peers that they
can be trusted on and this is why many
of the charities are local you know so
it's almost a signaling like if you if
you did if something I ever happened to
you I would put forth the same help to
you and so many of the long-term
projects do often get neglected right
not only because you can't put a number
on them and there are longer-term issues
but also because of signaling reasons so
I think there's still a lot we could do
in terms of creating long term
beneficial futures and I think yeah we
should we should really get rolling on
it the future of civilization all these
conversations have been very important
I'm really happy that we've had them on
the show today yeah me too I think like
I think these conversations need to
happen often and they really really
change whole belief systems right like I
think thinking about AI ethics has
taught me a lot about human ethics yeah
I just taught me a lot about where I
think you know it is taught me a lot
about where I think where we could be
going and but also a lot of realisms and
biases that are prevalent and I think
just thinking through technologies as
almost like an anthropocentric lens that
you hold on to yourself you know and you
do learn a lot about about there too
yeah
yeah the more that we have these
conversations the more our mind gets
expanded into these different areas of
thought and then all of a sudden were
talking other people about it and we're
learning new things from them they're
learning new things from us and remember
you get to pick what you do with your
time you open up the computer you get to
pick are you going to watch things that
are just there to entertain you or just
very mundane things or are you going to
watch things that provoke very
interesting thought about where we
should go in our future because join the
global conversation join existential
holcom join the foresight Institute
let's ask you what is something that you
believe to be true that nobody else
believes to be true okay here's
something that might might be a little
right one thing is that I don't think
I'll die um but you know that might be
true that might not be true in this
system in this ecosystem here other
people believe that they're that they're
not going to die
I think one thing that and where I
thought that I might have been a little
bit too radical was talking about
simulation where someone recently and I
mean switched to the topic and they're
like well that would be horrible right
um learning that we're in a simulation
what am and and I yeah I was like why so
learning that witness relation to me
given if we knew that the simulation was
relatively stable and and we could talk
about that too but then to me it would
be a really great thing I would not mind
it I would be I would finally cried
reconciling and like quite quite nice to
some extent because it would mean that
it's not the burden of making the most
out of this universe it's not all on us
it's not about because right now it's
really this existential risk you know
like which right now we're the only ones
and create this future or not or as far
as we know but if we knew we're in a
simulation we knew that there are other
entities and beings out there that are
at least sufficiently similar to our job
value set even if very different than
they are complex and intelligent and
much more so than we are and there
they create making simulations and
experiments which i think is great
through and I think it will it would be
reconciling if we knew that this
simulation wasn't shut down sir I think
Nick Baz Luhrmann one of his earliest
papers an extensional risky write said
the biggest that or one of the biggest
threats would be someone plugging off
the simulation right now I'm having the
simulation and we can pray that no one
trips over the leg charger or the
machine running the simulation but I
think you know and I think all we can
consider whether or not we live in a
simulation is kind of like trying to
live in a world where what we do matters
right you know there's certain worlds
there's a world in which none of what we
do matters because either we're doomed
or because none of what we do matters
because we're gonna reach a good like a
positive outcome anyways but there's
this third possibility of where what we
do actually matters and if we don't know
what we're living in we should like you
know kaya rager and just pretend we live
in the world where it matters what we do
and whether or not we think we might
live in a simulation or not or whether
or not we have all the free will or not
yeah just do what you think is gonna
matter for the optimal future outcome of
the world yeah yeah every single day
wake up and do that and the more that
you do that the better of a world will
live in yeah yeah so what about what do
you thinks the most beautiful thing in
the world
I think the most beautiful thing in the
world is I think engaging in kind of
dialectic conversations that you know
which we're doing here but but I really
mean it I think definitely thinking
things through and thinking them through
some first principles and and also with
someone that is has an adversarial
attitude to yours although it is really
just so insanely and so insanely
gratifying yeah at the end whether or
not you reach like one example was on
the AI safety and the ethics there's got
to be execution as well so there's gonna
be execution of this there's got to be
execute philosophy so boring when you
just talk talk talk it can't be it can't
be verbal masturbation right verbal
masturbation there it is yeah our word
of the day
enough with the verbal masturbation
especially all the kids that are
currently in college they're also
annoyingly just philosophizing all the
time I'm like become an entrepreneur
build something into the world yeah yeah
yeah I think like one one where I
recently changed my mind and there was
in terms of AI ethics you know I always
thought I wouldn't I wouldn't mind it
very much if I was transcended by a
super intelligence that that is much
more complex than interesting in
conscious than than I am and and I I
think I still wouldn't wouldn't think
that would be a terrible world but I
thought that you know that would be
something that that eventually everyone
might agree to but I've become a little
bit more so on that in the sense that I
think what matters what
what matters is what current existing
value giving entities value and humans
are the value of giving entities right
now so probably what matters is what
they value and whether or not I
personally value or whether or not I
personally don't find it bad being
superseded by super intelligence right
other people do so um this kind of
notion that eventually will strip
ourselves from all human biases and
we'll reach the state where we realize
that you know that we might even be bad
for the planet and you know like that
the super intelligence that is much more
complex might do a better job here
probably well III I would I wouldn't be
closed to the possibility but I have
become more sober and arguing for that
that's the that that's an option that
people should consider that they
actually work yeah and and I think you
have to be realistic right if people
don't value future generations and have
like not a zero discount rage toward
future generations then they just don't
have that future that that discount rate
and whether or not how much you think
that either a super intelligent being
might be important or whether you think
that yeah we provided it as conscious or
how much you you personally think future
generations are important or not which I
certainly think they are very much so it
doesn't yeah it doesn't matter if if if
others don't think that way you have to
pick them up where they're starting and
you have to engage them in rational
discussion about this but knowing which
biases which species is and which shot
and biases we're prone to so I think
yeah we realism Steven Pinker calls it
conditional realism
I like cautious realism sorry
conditional optimism or cautious
optimism but nevertheless optimism and
and hope yeah
optimism caution or optimism that is a
really good maybe what's another one
skeptical optimism there's a bunch of
cautious optimism this is a good way of
thinking this is a good way to look at
your news feeds and just be like that is
not real news I have to go and look five
other sources to know if it's real or
not there's all the conversations about
utopia if so many people are saying
utopia is not real utopia it won't
happen utopia can take
what about each person having their own
utopia would that you what would that
look like with everybody could we what
if somebody wants to kill people in
their utopia how do we solve that
problem what does our future with AI
look like our future with biotech our
future with blockchain this thank you on
thank you and what does the future look
like with all these different
technologies how do we build it together
how do we have more of these dialectic
conversations that are stop provoking
that are economists nobody's raging here
we're just chilling and talking houses
this has been such a pleasure to have
you on the show what's really good thank
you and we'll hopefully do part two soon
we have a lot more to unpack them thank
you Ron or producer/director thank you
guys good yeah we'll have to do more
soon existential hope calm foresight
Institute if you guys had a good time
like comment subscribe make sure to let
us know your thoughts share the video
with other people join us on patreon to
help us support the project and we'll
see you guys later today with Andre
Watson thank you peace
[Music]